You are listening to radio lab radio from w n y.
S c e.
Can I just tell you a story? I don't have a choice. Do I?
What's the story? This takes me back to when I was 14 uh, Jack Kennedy,
John F. Kennedy was the president and he's very glamorous. I mean you really,
he was on television. He was fun to watch and he would, he,
he would go to mass in my neighborhood in New York when he come to New York,
he go to a particular church all the time. And just out of enthusiasm,
some of my friends and I would go and stand there and watch him.
Just walk up the steps with you can even see the president of the United States
and his wife. So you did this multiple times? Many times. Yes. Cause he,
we were big fans and then one day we went to do that and I can't remember
whether he zipped by or zipped in, but anyway, we missed it.
And my friend John had, damn,
but he was a New York kid so he thought it would be interesting.
He knew that the place where President Kenny was staying,
which was a famous hotel on Madison Avenue,
and he came up with this crazy plan that he was going to ask for his aunt when
we walk into the lobby. So the secret service wouldn't have to worry about us.
So we go to the hotel, he does the thing,
we're in the lobby and then crazily the elevator door opens and there is
president Kennedy steps out of the elevator with Jackie. Wow.
She's immediately grabbed by these reporters and they were asking her something
and he's got nothing to do. So he used to politician,
he glances around and I am standing behind the potted plant staring at him.
And so he steps towards the Bush and he reaches over the Bush and goes,
hello young man, or something like that.
And I couldn't speak because there was so much phlegm coming flooding into my
throat that I thought I might drown standing up.
But they took his hand and I shook it
[inaudible]
and then he released,
he went off to do something else and I was just staring at my hand
later that day. I said to my sister, I shook president Kennedy's hand,
and I guess I'm not gonna wash it for like two days, two weeks maybe.
What did she say to you? I don't remember what she said, but,
but that's a funny thing to say.
When 50 years later you're a science reporter.
[inaudible]
look good,
Huh?
Because at the moment I thought, oh, Kennedy on unpopular.
Ooh, I didn't, I didn't know that was true. It was a panic.
Kind of like a dream thing that everybody has. I think with celebrities, I do.
Okay.
But now it turns out we can examine the question scientifically.
There's now a science that can do that. What do you mean? Well,
first of all, we all know this. We're covered with Germans. With bacteria. Yes.
But what I did realize is that there are scientists who say the bacteria,
honest, they clean to us almost like for life,
so you can be identified by your microbes and these scientists are now making
the bold claim that they can check those microbes to solve crimes,
to detect diseases, to do public health kind of things. I thought, well,
really I'm going to I,
why not put them to the test areas [inaudible] people and go after this small
little bit of personal history I got. So I decided to,
to reproduce the John F. Kennedy,
Robert Krulwich handshake as an experiment.
I thought we can, we could have,
I could find somebody who would beat President Kennedy who would shake my hand
and we would measure and calculate and see.
So I got a team of producers on our w NYC show,
only human to help me doing this. And we found a scientist,
Jack Jack, Jack. Jack Gilbert is director of the microbiome center,
the University of Chicago.
And then I don't have president Kennedy around anymore, so I got myself,
you're going to be president Kennedy for these purposes.
Substitute President Kennedy. Okay. Can you do a JFK by the way,
our nation will put a man on the moon safely through, no,
no. This is Neil degrasse Tyson,
director of the Hayden Planetarium with the American Museum of Natural History
here in New York. Well, have you ever been shot?
Have you ever had your handshake and by a person who you let that you feel like
you'd like to have his or her stuff sustained? Yeah, I, I'm,
I'm not that weird or creepy.
No, this, there's no part of anyone else. I just want to,
what about, what about if a, if you got Carl sagans underwear,
would you keep Karl sagans underwear?
No, but I have,
I have come to love and embrace all bacteria that want a part of my body.
You are awesome and so am I your man for this.
You absolutely need a man for this and
I will so pick up food that fell on the floor and needed me to do that.
Me Too. I don't even wait five seconds, which is always booked.
We knew it was bullshit. Anyway, I said, let me, let me,
let me explain what it is. Wait, I want to do, I don't think,
no one exactly knows the answer to this question,
but if a person shakes in another person's hands for eight ordinary interval,
then the question is how much a person a lands on person B and how much of
person a stays on person B, but most crucially fork.
How long presumably there's an exchange. Yes. So we're, we're nicking off.
You do back and forth. No Miss Hands though. Now that I'm looking at them, it's,
I know when I tried to find gloves it doesn't work. So it's three x l.
All right, so, so just so you,
we can give us like the fact that you are carrying all these microbes on you.
First of all, where are they predominately,
sorry. Every mucosal surface in your body, so your mouth,
your gastrointestinal tract, all the way down your skin, your fingernails,
you urogenital tract, your is every part of you that your butt, your butt,
especially your butt is covered in bacteria. And just sitting here,
you're actually releasing into the air around you think pig pen from the peanuts
cartoon. Remember about 36 million bacterial cells an hour. So every minute,
how do they come off of me? They are literally leaving on the,
on the surface of your skin cells that you're shedding and through your rest
respirations coming out of your nose and your mouth. Okay. Also detaching.
So they, a lot of them on,
they dry out on the surface and they can literally just drift off as dust or so.
But just so you understand this, the, the, uh,
the anatomy of the room all over this room on the doorknob,
on the table surface, on his pants, on the desk, and on the chairs,
there's Neal everywhere. A lot of them had, um, colonic kneel, right?
So a lot of them actually coming out of his, out of your pants, right?
And there they are on the surface of the chair and they deposit final Patina of
multi syllabic word. But we, I think we understand what you're
[inaudible] is it just, it's the largest resource.
It's there just to get out of me. And it does cry all the time. All the time.
So that means this is not a bathroom or boxes of chairs would have the most.
Yes. All right, so now let me just time question real quick. So Jay,
so Jack needs about 20 minutes to do for us to do this handshake.
That's by the way producer Kenny Malone. Why don't we,
why don't we start the experiment now and then we have time to talk in between.
Okay. All right. What are you going to do?
So what we're going to do is we have little tests.
I'm not offering you my butthole, [inaudible] and Tyson.
It doesn't mean I'm offering you my micro stand up. Sony's in front of me.
You we're going to do hands. Absolutely.
So we have these little stare out tubes, reach tubes,
they will green cap tube has a sterile swab in it with a,
with a completely sterile tip.
We're going to open that up and very quickly rub very vigorously each of your
hands. So your palm,
the inside of your fingers and we're going to do that very big scene and put it
as quickly as possible back into this, there on this your control sample.
This is the start starter. Okay.
Then you are going to shake hands with the a young man over there.
Right with Robert. And we're going to definitely,
I try and see how many you have received from Neil and how many Neil is received
from Robert.
Wait,
he is swabbing your hands before you handshake so that he can figure out what's
the baseline that you've got on both of your hands. [inaudible] right.
And he sure you're going to have different bacteria on your, on your hands,
you and Neil. Yes.
So this is where it gets very interesting.
So you have very specific types of bacteria and he has very specific types of
bacteria, but they're unique to you.
I mean I guess like, I mean like if I just think about it for a second,
like the two of you had different days, you arrive in this office,
you've probably touched different places, you've eaten different things.
So okay, maybe you have a little bit of difference. But in general, hmm.
You are both men living in New York City breathing the same air,
riding the same subways. Exactly.
So why would you be that different from one another? Well,
because there's one very important difference between us. Oh, okay.
We have different mothers.
So have you been told anything? Like what?
This is about a little bit about the microbiome,
but I'm happy to hear more. This is Dr Chavonne Dolan.
I'm an obstetrician gynecologist and I'm actually a clinical geneticist as well.
And we brought her in because she knows more than most of a when it comes to
moms and babies. During my training years,
probably delivered a hundred babies a year. So that was about 500 babies.
Then I was in private practice at Yale new haven hospital for a bunch of years
and I probably delivered another couple hundred and I have three kids myself.
So I was on, I was on the other side as well. Okay.
And she says as a fetus before you're born, you're, you know,
exposed to what's in the amniotic fluid.
But it's a pretty clean set up in utero.
But then you go through the vagina and the vagina is just a host of bacteria and
you know, he [inaudible] amniotic fluid. There's blood.
And this moment is in essence, your bacterial baptism. Right, exactly.
Because at this point you're this pristine, unadulterated hunk of biomass,
the bacteria, they're like, yeah, give me a ride. I'm going to jump on.
Yeah. The bacteria colonize that, that surface cause that's what bacteria do.
And so finally, when the baby's born,
the doctors, they take it,
you make sure they're stable breathing and then right up onto mom to start to
immediately promote the bonding and the skin to skin.
[inaudible]
in your own case, if you can remember like what happened,
like what I remember is just crabbing for him, like your mind and I,
I've been waiting nine months to meet you and here you are.
And like just kind of embracing him and looking in his eyes.
And so there's a third of bonding there that I will never forget.
And in the same moment you're going to get some micro bonding too. Um, it's a,
it's a very dynamic. Yeah. Hug and bacteria go pew.
They leap from the mom's skin onto the baby. Um, I,
I did this for both my children. I,
I took both of them onto my bare chest at birth. And,
but you wanted to compete against your wife, Huh? Absolutely.
Maybe a little bit of daddy was a, was a helpful thing, you know, who knows? So,
yeah, I uh, that, that was the reason I did it. And the thing is, well,
we'll start, so I'll, I'll take your first one.
You just strains of bacteria that we get in those first few hours. Okay.
I'm sorry. Give me a right hand. And then to a lesser degree,
the bacteria that we meet later in the first year of our life,
when we stick weird things in our mouth at the dog comes by. You're ready? Yup.
Those strains of bacteria stick with us forever. God, nope.
I'm gonna swap it as much as possible. Even the bacteria, the Jack,
we'll find it tickles now in Neil's hand, rub it on my hand.
All over the finger between okay.
Are descendants of those first moments of contact area and I'm okay.
And crazily enough. Gotcha.
Even if you try to get rid of your bacterial inheritance, you know,
put up Savlon, get rid of all your skin bacteria,
take lots of antibiotics and get rid of all you're telling me bacteria,
and then move to some completely different part of the world where the food is
different than the different still
the bacteria you got from your mom will come creeping back. Why, why would they,
why would that be? Well,
the thing in ecology called the founder effect,
whereby the first organisms to get there and to be successful in an environment,
um, they alter the trajectory of the rest of the ecosystem and change how it
develops, right? So, you know, if a tree species interrupt the tree,
lands on an island and, and becomes dominant,
then it will support the types of birds and the types of monkeys and the types
of insects that love that type of tree. Um, and so the same is true in,
in the microbiome. So you, you know, you have a,
a lifelong partnership with the bacteria you interacted with.
So we know that Neil and I each have a unique mix of microbes almost to the
point where they're like a fingerprint. But if we shake hands,
just a mere hello handshake, how much of his is going to get on me,
how much of mine is going to get on him and most important of all is how long
will the exchange microbially last.
So next step you guys got to shake hands.
I want you to shake hands like just as if you were meeting in the hall and you
were like, Hey Neil or hey Robert, nice to meet you and just shake hands.
Okay. Yep, they're ready now I have to like think about how to actually shake
[inaudible] to three Robert
[inaudible]. Okay,
now right hand go can feel like I'm going to grab my index finger too cause you
got to look on the palms. Didn't, didn't touch her as much as me.
And so every five minutes for the next 20 minutes and then we're going to swap
your hand again.
Jack Swab both Neil's hand and my hand actually pulling off a slight Patina of
bacteria. But yeah,
just checking to see if any bacteria moved and for how long. So wait, wait,
what happened? Did he did? Yeah. Wait, what happened? Wow.
Why would I tell you now when we have the advantage of a short break,
we'll be right back.
[inaudible]
Nicole from Corning, New York,
where do you lab to support it in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hello, this is Tom leads from Oaklawn, Illinois radio lab and need your help,
please visit w n y c Dot.
Podcasting survey.com and tell them a little bit about yourself and the podcast
you love and a five minute anonymous survey I did.
You can find the link on the show page for this episode Radio Lab.
Really appreciate your help.
Knowing more about you helps them make more of the shows that you enjoy.
Thank you very much.
Jad Robert Radiolab. By the way,
do you have a hint as the outcome of this thing that we've just done like, okay.
Just before we went to break, Robert Neil had just
shaking hands and Jack Gilbert was going to swap those hands right while minutes
off the handshake and then around every five minutes for about 25 minutes.
What exactly does he do after he swaps him? He takes the,
takes our bacteria back to the lab and he identifies our bacteria by their DNA.
Yeah, that's exactly it. I mean it's true. This is a whole new science,
isn't it? I mean like there are a thousand things you could wonder about. Well,
yes, it is a whole new science. It's the science that is on the cutting edge.
We know we're still researching and developing it and it will take many years
before we were ready for prime time, but Jackson has,
they are now at the phase where they can look into all kinds of different
applications for this new microbiome detecting ability. Take for example,
forensics.
Imagine if somebody comes into a room and doesn't evil deed right now.
We know that when somebody interacts with that space for 15 minutes,
they leave behind enough of the signature too for us to be able to detect 30
minutes later, Huh.
If I had to pick between three people or four people that were to break into a
room,
there's a good possibility that I could detect which one of them had broken into
that room. Wow. And they're only going to get better and better. He says,
do you think maybe one day you'll be able to track somebody like outside moving,
moving around purely on the, based on the bacteria that they leave behind?
That's exactly what we're investigating.
He also says being able to identify bacteria in a town sewer system will be
really useful in helping us to predict a potential outbreak by noticing that
there's a disease causing bacteria right in the sewage.
So you can go to town and before anyone begins to show symptoms,
you could say something like, wait a second, we've got a quarantine, vaccinate,
we gotta do something here and nip it in the bud, if you will,
before it becomes a problem. And as you may have heard,
there's plenty of research looking at the microbiome inside of you.
It's revolutionizing medicine. I mean,
we already have evidence that we can determine whether somebody will have a bad
response to a drug based on the bacteria that are present inside them.
So we can screen them using their microbiome to determine if they have that
likely outcome. But for now, come on. Yes, come on. It's not true.
This absolutely crucial and breathtaking experiment.
So let me just quickly remind you of the situation. When we last left you,
you and I.
So a couple of weeks later we got the results from Jack and so I decided to go
to Neil to deliver them. Right. And just to set up expectations here,
Jack told us what he expected was immediately after our handshake.
A little bit of me would be on Neil,
a little bit of Neal would be on me and that we know pretty fast the bacteria
would die and be gone. However,
I am very happy to say that. Isn't that what happened?
What percentage change would you guess you caused on me of me on you?
A 10% 10% that I, I can't imagine it.
I would say 1% 10%, but not much. Less than 1%.
While it
was less than 10 [inaudible] when they came back,
it was a significantly less than 10. Okay.
It was zero. Zero. Well, it can't be zero.
It'd be below there, whatever it is. Right. Okay.
Actually they found a teeny number of bacteria, but they died.
There was essentially nothing. Nothing from Neal. Yes. Nothing.
It's just, it's just, it's just odd.
Should I put it that way? I mean, um, that was quite shocking.
We were expecting there to be a lot more bacteria being transferred and,
and to have an exchange of microbes so that, you know, yeah,
one person picks up 10 bacteria, the other person picks up, you know, 10,
12 bacteria.
I didn't think you might've washed your hand immediately. Previous,
I don't think. No, no. There was no, no, no sabotage or anything.
Use an alcohol wipe. But I hate antibacterial. I don't use,
what do you call the, um, Purell? I never use any of it.
So for reasons that are at this moment totally unknown,
Neil's bacteria simply failed completely to, uh,
affect my hand.
The other side of this equation is what would you guess the presence of my
microbes on you was? Percentage. Okay.
What I know from physics of surfaces is if they have approximately the same
coefficient of friction, then it's, it's a complete two way street.
So if I gave you nothing you would have given me nothing is my guess.
Here's what happened.
He definitely picked up bacteria from you and that led to quite substantial
disruption.
It turns out I smog your hand.
You telling me you were skank nasty. I
told you what happened. They don't understand what happened.
Skank I came on funky.
The percentage before the handshake was that you and I were 60% the same,
40% different
post shake. You were more than 75% correlated
to you.
You made him more you by 15% at least I was swerving all over again.
I'm slightly proud and kind of trouble, but at the same time,
not only did you get my microbes,
but my kept staying and staying and staying every time they swamp.
I was still there six minutes later, 12 minutes later. That's nasty.
Could it have been an hour later? I might might still be on his hand.
Yeah. I mean I'm, there's no indication that they were in decay
when I left. You were covered with
let the record show he beat his chest. In that moment
it looks like there was a possibility that they,
some of them could have gone on ad infinitum
and then for night. And what do you mean?
Even though you think that I might stay on him?
Oh,
what I think is that there's a high probability that some of those organisms,
once they set up shop on his hand in those initial 20 minutes could stay on his
hand. What
do you mean like forever? Like forever and ever?
There is a possibility. There is a possibility. Precisely.
Uh,
do we have any idea whether what we've just described is typical of a common
handshake experience? My, my gut feeling is this is atypical. Why I'll wait,
because they may be out all out competed.
Jack says to understand just how strange this result is.
Let me think about it this way. Two hands coming together,
taking a right in forest.
I'm from Bolivia in extra and dumping it on top of a rain forest in Brazil.
And,
and wondering whether any of the trees from the Bolivian rainforest will take
root and you know, and uh, adapt and become prolific in that environment. Oh,
so the invaders don't really have a huge shot here. Then, you know,
you'll bacteria have home field advantage.
They are abundant and they are dominant in that environment.
So we would generally suspect that very quickly the invading microbes start to
die. That killed off. Um, they starve and they just become inactive.
So it's happens and it's over and nobody wins. Precisely.
There's mutual decay.
So am I now a successful invasive species on his hands where some of your
microbes are successful invasive species, but yeah, absolutely.
How would you explain my success?
What we think actually happened is that something disrupted Neil's ecosystem,
right? Um,
and we think based on the analysis that there was a strip to caucus,
which is usually quite rare, but that doesn't sound so good step to caucus.
Well there are lots of species of streptococcus,
but not all of them are pathogenic.
So there was a strip to caucus that was very abundant on your hand at the
beginning that was transferred to Nielsen and we see that transfer occurring and
that streptococcus somehow, um,
disrupted Neil's ecosystem and allowed for a greater transfer of bacteria from
your hand to his hand. Oh man, that's so interesting.
So you have like a little band of like murderous little bacteria and then when
and, and, and, and cleared away the forest and then let,
so that the rest of you could come in and colonize. I don't know.
I don't think anybody knows the answer to that question. All I know is that I'm,
I'm all over the map.
I don't mind some of Robert slathered on my body. That's fine.
Do you feel any defensiveness towards the fact that he managed to
conquer your microbiome and yet yours was unable to do the same to him?
That by the way, is producer Simon Adler. So the word conquer in that context,
I would reword the sentence and say my microbiome was perfectly content staying
where it is
and apparently Robert's microbiome can't wait to get the hell off his body,
man.
I came here thinking I would find out how long President Kennedy stayed on me.
Now there's suddenly a new question because if he's a cool cucumber,
it's I want you stayed on him.
Yeah.
I believe in this nation.
[inaudible] turn and turn safely. Say you're here.
Mm.
Yeah. Maybe you're the anomaly. Yeah.
You're the creepy sweaty man with wet palms. That's what you come here for.
Like the repast
[inaudible]
system such as you
need an old immovable object like me.
You can, as your resume,
something's gotta give something's gotta give something to God.
Big thanks to astrophysicist and author Neil degrasse Tyson for putting up with
this shenanigans. I can go five days without a shower and you wouldn't know it.
The man is smelling his armpits for the moment,
but with just the look that moment like I just don't smell.
You want me smell your art?
I don't want you to just wonder if it smells terrible.
Then if you on the way to smelling Ben. Oh yes.
But it's not repulsive. I'm never
[inaudible] has got a gift.
This story was produced by Simon Adler.
Big thanks to Jared, myself,
who did a lot of the technical work of the lab work that gave us higher
microbial analysis also to the Montefiore medical center also to science writer
and author Ed Young, whose book I contain.
Multitudes is a primer on all things microbiomics and it was talking to ed where
I began thinking, Oh yeah, that Jack Kennedy handshake.
So that's how this whole thing got started.
And then when things really got going,
that's when the team at Wny sees only human kicked in. That's Amanda Aronchick,
Elaine Chan, Kenny Malone, Julian Weinberger. These are the ones who were,
who were with me all the way and stuck with this whole crazy thing with the
swabs and whatever.
And speaking of which, if you want to get in on the action,
this is kind of cool. Uh, so, uh, the whole JFK situation that Robert just did,
you can kind of do it to this company called ubiome has offered the chance 4,000
listeners, a thousand listeners to get sent some swabs,
which you will swipe on your hand, put it in a envelope, I assume,
and then mail it back.
They will sequence it and then tell you all the stuff that's on your hand.
And you can start that whole process by going to our website,
radiolab.org or only human.next
week. They are putting on their own show,
which involves a microbial robbery that is, can catch the robber.
If all you can see you the microbes. I believe your house figures into that.
Yes. There's an actual robbery in my home. Yes.
And also go to our website because along with only human,
we are putting up a very short animation of the handshake situation done by Nate
Milton, which is a, it's just gloriously weird.
Oh, a quick reminder. You can listen to radio lab anytime on Spotify.
Good yet I would shake your hand, but I.